よろしくお願いします
三十番目ですね 今日は
アッパマーデーナ マガワ デーワナン セッテタン ガトー アッパマーダン チャメー ダウィ アッパマーダン パサ
ン サンティ パマドゥ ガライトウ サダアッパマーデーナ マガワ デーワナン セッテタン ガトー アッパマー
ダン パサン サンティ パマドゥ ガライトウ サダ
と またもう一度 このアッパマーダという不放逸って何なのかと
怠らないことって何なのかっていうもう一つの偈なんです
この仏教のこのアッパマーダ
怠らないこと 不放逸 それがキーワードですから
あの そう簡単に日本語でただ不放逸と言っただけで意味は通るわけじゃないんです
日本語にしたっても 他の言葉にしたっても
そう訳できる言葉ではないんです
単純な意味は怠らないというね
怠けないというぐらいの意味は単純な意味なんですけどね
しかし なぜ仏教のすべての実践
すべての修行 仏道というそのものがアッパマーダという一言葉に集約されてまとめてありますし
釈尊も最後の言葉として残したのも
このアッパマーダという一言葉なんですね
不放逸で頑張ってくださいというような一言葉なんですね
それで 何の意味ですかと
このアッパマーダっていうのは
それで意味は あの ただ我々
私たちは日本語であっこの意味だよっていう風に
そういう風に簡単に理解してやろうと思っちゃうと
あの頭はそのまんまで成長はしないんです
頭はすごく余裕のままで残しちゃうんです
ですから まあそういう単純に
あ これはこれやという風に理解して納得するんではなくて
この深い意味がありますから
あの ゆっくりゆっくりと理解していった方がいいと思います
それで このアッパマーダという章の中で
一つ一つの偈で 一つ一つの側面
同じ言葉の一つ一つの側面を
あの 強調しているんです
それで あ もう まあ例えばもう番目のアッパマーダは何の意味か
番目のアッパマーダは何の意味か
二十七番目 八番目のアッパマーダの意味は何なのかと調べると
それぞれ変わっていくんですよ
意味は これ 同じアッパマーダという言葉の一つ一つの側面の意味
意味を強調しているんです
それ全部もうまとめて理解すれば
ああなるほど アッパマーダっていうのはこういうものであるということは
もうなんとなくわかると思います
しかし では日本語でどう訳すればいいかといったっても
これは日本人にもできないと思います
いくら理解しても  そういうことで
あの そういうやり方で勉強するものなんです
で 大体こういう心の言葉っていうのはね
まあ簡単単純じゃないんですからね
まあ豆腐の味は何なのかといえば
まあそれはそんなに大したことではないし
説明まあできる できなかったら食べてみればよろしいし
また まあどなたかそんな簡単で豆腐の味がわかるわけないんだよと
沖縄から北海道までいろいろなところでいろんな豆腐作ってるんだからね
それで日本の豆腐の味がわかるわけないではないかとかね
まあ言うと まあそういう場合はやっぱりもう沖縄から北海道まで豆腐食いながら歩かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
まあまあ それにしても大した変わりがないと思いますけどね
で そういう風に簡単で理解できるものじゃないので
心の問題の場合はね 例えば嫉妬って何なのかというと
私たちはそのその経験で嫉妬ってこんなもんだよというふうに言えるものじゃないんですよ
だからまあ いろんな場面でどんなふうに機能するかっていうふうに見なくちゃいけない
例えば嫉妬にしたっても
もうまるっきり同じようなものじゃないんですよ
嫉妬する人と嫉妬される側というのは
その関係によってもう無数に無制限の嫉妬の種類が出てくるんですね
これが無制限なんですね
で 同じ嫉妬する人も そのその土地によって
日にち経つたびに自分の自分の嫉妬の形も変わるし
嫉妬の対象になっているものもどんどん変化していくんだからね
それによってももう嫉妬の質が変わっていくし
だから嫉妬ってどういうものかというふうな一言葉で言いなさいよと言っても
そう言えるものじゃないんです
すごくこの心の状況っていうのは
そういうふうな状況なんですね
単純な数学的にね 測ってみて理解できるものではないんですね
それは心に関わるどんな言葉でも同じものなんです
例えば頑張りましょうって
それどういうものか意味かとね
わからないでしょうしね
精進しましょうと言ってもね
どんな言葉でも同じことになるんですよ
若者が私は恋しているんだそうと言うと
ああそうか 我々わかったような顔をするでしょう
わからないと思いますよ
恋といったっても みんなワンパターンで同じ恋をしているわけじゃないんですよ
し だから同じ人が同じ人に対する恋も
もういろいろ変わるんですね
初めて会った日である
もう感情と もうまだまだもう繰り返し合う時の感情というのはそれぞれ変わっていくんです
でも一言葉でまあ 1年間も恋していたんだと
それから別れたというふうなことになるかもしれませんだけどね
それで別れたと言ったっても
では嫌で別れたんで それまたバラバラでしょ
本当は別れたくないのに
もう別れなくてはいけないことになったとか
フラれたっていうこともあるでしょうね
フラれる場合は自分では別れたくないでしょうね
だから失恋の痛みもそれぞれ違うんですよ
自分ではもっともういい人に出会って
そちらにアタックしたくて
この人をもう振ってしまう場合の
何でしたっけ この別れの苦しみと
ただ自分がもう ずっとその人のことに執着してるんですけど
相手に振られた時の苦しみとかね
だから言葉では同じなんですね
振られた振ったとぐらいの単純な言葉なんですけど
心の状況はどうなのかっていうのは
これすごく把握しにくいほど複雑なんですね
で まあ複雑とも言えない
とにかくもう数字的には理解できない
まあ物理的に言えば空気の大きさ説明してくださいというようなものなんです
物理知ってる人だったらもうバカバカらしい質問ですよ
空気の大きさ説明してくださいっていうのは
もうなんとか木の大きさとか
なんとか他のものの大きさなんか言ってくださいったら
これは言えますよ 重さ測ってでも大きさは言えるんですよ
でも空気の場合はそう言えないんです
例えば 10gぐらいの空気の大きさはどれぐらいですか？と
どうやって得るんですかね
だから空気っていうのは
空気の分子っていうのは好き勝手で動き回るんだから
空間があれば動き回る
そういうことだから 大きさっていうのは言えないんですね
だからどこら辺で閉じ込められているかっていうことを言ってくれないと
それ言ったら本人が大きさ知ってるんだからね
別に聞く必要はないでしょうし
まあだから心の状態もそんな感じで
まああの なかなか言いにくいもので
今日は別にそういうところではなくて
アッパマーダと不放逸と言えば
努力する 頑張る 怠けないっていう
そういういろんな意味がありますよ
それって何の意味なのかと
それで今日はもう 30番目の偈で
今日はある一つの意味なんです
これで全てというわけじゃないんです
えーと アッパマーダ・ヴァッガの 1番目は何でしたっけ
アッパマーダ 番号は 20？ 21です
ああ 21 21から説明してくるんだから
じゃあ今日は30だからね
だから9回もアッパマーダの定義をしたんです
別々な定義 で 今日で 9回になります
では 説明に入ります アッパマーデーナ マガワー デーヴァーナン セッタタン ガト
マガワーっていうのは固有名詞である人の名前なんです
だからマガワーっていうのは
マガワーという マガワーという人ですね
デーヴァーナン セッタタン ガト
デーヴァーナンというのは複数形で神々の間で
神々の中で セッタタンっていうのは
セッタっていうのは一番トップということでね
頂点に立ったと リーダーに
一番トップの神になりましたと
セッタタン ガト そういう立場になりましたと
このマガワーという人が神々の中で一番トップになってしまったんです
どんなことで？賄賂でですかね
何か特別な何か宣伝でもしたんでしょうか
そうではないんです アッパマーデーナ
アッパマーダによって
不放逸によって 神々の世界で一番目の上のトップのような神々の王になってしまったんです
マガワーという人は だからそれだけでこの偈文の意味で終わっちゃいます
すぐにあるのはすごい簡単
アッパマーダン パサンサンティ
だからアッパマーダということ
不放逸ということは よく称賛される
称賛されるものだよと
当たり前ですからね もし神々の間でもトップになれるんだったら
アッパマーダで だったらアッパマーダというのはいいものだと誰でも思うでしょう
パマード ガラヒトー サダー
そちらの反対のことはパマード
放逸 怠けること 怠けることは非難されるんですよ
ガラヒトっていうのはすごく非難される
で 放逸 不放逸は称賛される
で これでだったらわからないでしょ
何が不放逸ですかね 神々のマガダという人はどうやって神々のトップに王になったんでしょうか
これはアッパマーダということで
これ何やと あれはとわからないでしょ
不放逸ということは何か呪文でしょうかとかね
で 大体その偈ではわからないんですね
しかし この中偈だけでわかることは
この世の中で上達したければ
向上したければ 前に進みたければ
エネルギーはたった一つアッパマーダなんです
これがあれば前に進むんだよと
上達はするんだよと そこでこのマガダという人が神々の間で王になった
それ以上上がるとこないんだからね
頂点まで上がってしまったと
だからそれは普遍的に見たら
もうどんな生命にしたっても
自分をよりベターな人間に
より優れた人間にしたければ
たった一つだけですよね
やるべきことは この不放逸ということで
それぐらいの理解でしかこの偈では言えない
だからこのマガダという言葉を使ったのは
これはインドにあったある神話なんです
で インドにあった神話は
仏教になってくるといろいろ変症して仏教的な神話にするんです
だいたい物語っていうのはインドであったものなんですよ
仏教は全部自分のものにする
自分のものにする場合は
そのまんま受けるんじゃなくて
いろいろもうストーリーを変えるんです
で 神々の王にはインドラという名前がありまして
インドラっていうのは
普通は古いアーリア言語の世界ではもう王という意味に使う言葉なんです
ですから ドイツ語で何でしたっけね
王は  王はケーニヒです
ん？キング？え？ ケーニヒ
ドイツ語で王はケーニヒ
古いドイツ語で何と言うか
このAlthochdeutschというところちょっと似ている
そこら辺でも同じ言葉だと思いますけど
とにかくこのインドラという言葉っていうのは信じられないほど古いんです
で この このアーリアという民族がね
インドあちこち広げていきましたから
この古代文明の時代で
その人々はインドに入っちゃって
インド文化というものを作り出しちゃったんですね
そこでまあ まあどちらかというと
まあモンゴル人民と似ていて
騎馬民族ですけど モンゴル系では全くないんです
これはもうどこから現れたかわからないんですけど
おそらくイランやらイランという言葉も全く同じアーリアという言葉ですから
そこら辺はアーリア民族の国でしたかもしれませんし
そこからヨーロッパに行ったり
東に広げたりしたりしてね
中央アジアともいう あれも中央アジアですから
そういういろいろ説はあります
誰もはっきりわかりません
その時の戦いにインドに行く時は
自分たちの守り神ですか
もう戦争ですからね で
守り神なんですね このインドラっていうのは
それがインドラさんがインドラという神の言葉はどんどん言語化になって
王という意味で使っているんです
だから今インドラといえば
神か王かどちらですね
どちらにでも使う 普通の人間の名前にも使います
別に で これでそれぞれの同じアーリア民族と言ってもすごく大きいんだから
その中でもいろいろグループがたくさんなったりして
だからそのそのグループは自分なりの神を信じているんですね
で この戦いの神が戦って国を支配したら
この司令官が王になっちゃうでしょうし
ですから戦いの神 戦争の神が神の中でも論理的に王にする
なるんですよ 単純なこの人間の論理でね
だからといって インドラ神は必ずしも王の中で神々の中で王にならなくちゃいけないという法律はないんですけど
もう人間作ってる物語だからね
人間の次元で見れば 誰かが暴力の人がいて
隣の国と戦って潰して人殺してもう潰したところで
王は誰ですかというと
この人でしょうね 行って殺した人が王になるでしょうに
だから自分たちの戦争に勝たせてくださいと
お祈りする神はもう自然に神の世界で王に
王として崇めたり考えたりするっていうことは普通の流れなんですね
思考の これでインドラ王が
インドラ神が神々の王であるということをアーリア人の間で広げてやって
もうどんどんどんどんその信仰が増えていくんです
それで一旦ブッダの時代っていうのはもうかなり後の時代だから
この文明の始まりっていうのはそれよりも3000年ぐらい古い話で
もっと古いと思いますけど
だからまあお釈迦様の時代になってくると
もう全然わからない もうこの人間どこから来たのかっていうことは
その時になってくるともう2 3
年ぐらい古いですからね
しかし みんな人間の間で
民族の間でいろんな信仰がある
その中であれこれとか
いろんな神々を信仰しているんですけど
神の王としてインドラという人
神も崇めているんですね
そこでそのいろんな神に関わるエピソードも大量にある
神話というものはいくらでもある
残念なことに インドの神話やら何やらもう物質
本にしないんだから もうほとんど死んでいるんですよ
もし文化的にはもうかなり文化古いんだから
もし文書として残したならば
もう信じられないほど量があると思います
だから今も結構ありますけど
それに中国と比べると中国ではそんなにたくさんないんですよ
あれほど大きい国ですけど
大きくなったのはそんな遠い昔の話ではないしね
中国もバラバラバラバラでしたし
で いろんな民族が集めて中国ができていて
その民族の物語やらね
ほとんど潰されちゃいますからね
結局は小さくなるんですけど
インドではそんなに民族的には差がなかったんですけど
アーリア人とアーリア人でない連中という
ちょっと二つしかなかったし
しかし アーリア人とアーリア人でない人々っていうのは一緒にいたんです
殺し合いやら差別やら
それはしなかったんです
で ずっと仲良く一緒にいる
どちらが まあどちらかというと
やっぱり政治権力を握っちゃったんだから
アーリア民族の方がちょっと非ロゲは大きいし
今もインドにも半分以上はアーリア民族ですけど
結構アーリアでない民族も何人かいる
タミル人も一つで またいくつかいるんです
別に仲良くは生活しています
もう性格悪いのはこのタミル人だけですけど
で インドでもどこでもちょっとアホくさいというかね
他の人々は結構もうそれなりにちゃんと共存することこそかっこいいと思ってるしね
それはどうでもいいことで
まあ広げてあって そこでいろんな神話が出来上がっちゃう
いろんな民族グループが自分の神話があって
それを後の世代に伝えたりする
で だからこれ親から教えてもらわなきゃ
もう神話がわからないし
その人が自分の親に教えてあげなかったらそれそれ信じちまっちゃうし
だからもう広げている神話は残るんですけどね
かなり語り語り続けている神話は残る
だからこのインドの聖書として崇めているマハーバーラタっていうのは
そういう神話の集まりなんですね
で それも誰か誰かが一本にまとめようとする
一本にはまとめません
とにかく基本的な単純なストーリー
何々さんが何々どこかへ行って
誰か誰か潰しておりなったというぐらいのもう二
三行のストーリーですよ
それに膨大なストーリーつけてもうまとめるんです
マハーバーラタのストーリーっていうのは
十人ぐらいの連中がもう自分戦いで自分の国を戻したというぐらいの話なんです
これの本というのはもう分厚くて
ものすごい何冊もあるんです
だからこのあらゆる神話をつなげる
つなげてつなげてつなげて
その中の一つはインドラの物語なんですね
だからインドラの神の説明してくださいってなかなか難しいんです
いろんな一神ありますからね
そこで仏教はインドラに別の名前を付けちゃったんです
マグワという おそらく仏教が来たと言ったっても
これ一つそのエピソードもあったと思います
インドでね インドラの神の名前はマガワン
マガワっていうのはパーリ語の格変化した時の言葉で
元はマガワンというサンスクリット語になってくると
マガはマガワンというのは道の人って意味なんですよ
いわゆる旅人って意味もあるし
そうではないかな これサンスクリット語じゃないんだから
パーリ語でもないんだから
本当に意味わからない
私も正直なところ推測ではあまり言ってはいけないんです
それマガという言葉の
意味っていうのは これサンスクリット語じゃなくても
もっと以前の原始アーリア言語で使っていた言葉ですからね
だから今分析しても意味が出てこないんですね
マックというのは まあヴェーダ語でどうなっているかもわからないし
もう どうでもいいんで
そのマガヴァンっていうのは
もうもともと人間でいた有名な人なんです
だから その人の物語を語り続けて
その人亡くなって天国に生まれたんだと
こんな立派な人が マガヴァンが天国に生まれたんだと
で なんでマガヴァンが天国に生まれたんですか？というエピソードがあるんです
それで天国に生まれただけじゃなくて
そちらで王に王になるんですね
天国でも それでマガヴァンのエピソード
もの神話物語があって
また天に王になった物語
またガチャガチャたくさんありますからね
で 全部まとめてインドラにするんです
だから性格的には関係ないんですよ
ある民族がある人の物語を語り続けて
その人は亡くなって天国に行って
天国でも王になりましたよと
別な民族も 何々さんがこういう風に生活していて
我々の偉大な王様がそれから亡くなって天国に行って
何のこともなく天国で王になりました
そうやってたくさん民族が物語持っているんですね
神話物語を これは全部統一しても困ったもんで
もうインドラという一言葉にまとめてしまう
だからインドラ神はってどんな神でしょうかと
教えてくれと言ったら
どんなストーリーを教えてあげればいいかということが分からなくなるんです
その中で仏教が選んだのは
このマガヴァンという人のエピソードなんです
戦争の神ということは
もうもう忘れようと捨てようとは努力しているんです
そんなことはない 知らんぞという
とあるんですけど やっぱり忘れることできないインドの一般文化だから
やっぱり戦いに行ったという話は出てあるんです
その時違う言葉を使うんですね
マガヴァンではなくて
これでだから この偈の意味を解説するためには
私たちはこのエピソードを読まなくちゃいけなくなるんです
マガヴァンの物語を 物語語るということは
もう私の日本語の能力ではできない
これ ただ単に昔々おじいさんとおばあさんがいましたという物語を言うためには
もうかなり日本語の能力が必要なんです
どんなバカにも哲学は語れますよ
でも こういう昔話 物語を言うためには
結構生々しい生き生きしている日本語が必要なんです
私はこれがもう知らない
日本の家庭でみんなと一緒に生きてみたことは一度もないし
ずっと一人で人工的な環境でいるんだから
知ってる日本語は全部人工的な日本語なんです
思想 哲学 解説はできるんですけど
物語はちょっと言いにくいんですね
だから実習で読むしかないんです
これは 日本語版はありますかね
その完全版は 結構長いんですけど
でお釈迦様はウェーサーリ国という国にいた時は
このリッチャビという人々の国でマハリ
マハリという あの一応親分ですね
その国の王たちの 彼がお釈迦様がサッカという
また別な名前のインドラです
あの その日本に伝わっているのはサッカという言葉で
たい 何戦？ 帝釈天  帝釈天
帝釈 でしたっけ あの男はすらゆとか
あれ何でしたっけ？あれ
え？うん 帝釈天 で この帝釈天として拝んでいるのは
そのサッカ パーリ語だったらシャッカ
サンスクリットでシャッカ
パーリ語でサッカ その神なんで
だからこれまた一つのエピソードなんです
だからいろいろエピソードをつなげているんだから
サッカって言えば神 神々の王なんですけど
サッカは何やった人かというとちょっと違うんですよ
エピソードは インドラといえば神様の王なんで
そうすると彼が何やった人かとまたエピソードが変わる
マガダンで神の王様ですよと
その人何やった人かと
またエピソードが変わっちゃう
で パーリ仏典 特にブッダの時代で
ブッダの世界ではこのマガダンというストーリーを強調したかったんです
あの人ごとの話じゃないんだぞと
これが本の話だよと 本当の話だよということ
で 後になってくると このサッコ・デーワーナ・ミンドーってパーリ語でも出てきますから
サッコ・デーワーナ・ミンドーという言葉が一般的になっちゃって
帝釈天にしているのはその名前なんです
そこでこのまあ 中部経典でもサッカパニ・スッタという長い経典がありまして
この帝釈天と釈尊が対話するんです
結構長いんです 対話する経典で
それで帝釈天が質問して
お釈迦様が答える それがそのことを言ったところで
マハーリ王が なんかお釈迦様はもうやけに褒めてるんだと
この帝釈天を 見たことでもあるのかと
モッサラカットルと という疑問なんです
怪しいんですよ こういうエピソードなんか
だからマハーリっていうのはもうそれははっきり生きてた
お釈迦様の時代に生きてたリッチウィクの王でしょうし
そちらそっちお釈迦様行く
お釈迦様と結構仲がいいし
それでその人のところでサッカパニ
帝釈天と対話した経典の内容とかなんとか
もう説明してあげたっても
それブッダのこと知ってる人だったら
いい ありがたい説法を聞いていただけましたとかね
それでもう納得すればいいでしょうし
なんで余計なことを 本当にお釈迦様帝釈天と会った
見たことあるんでしょうか？と
対話の話ですからね 帝釈天とこういう対話がありましたよという話で
見たことあるんでしょうかと疑問にするのも何かちょっとわからないんですね
この間 何々さんとこういうふうに話がありますと言ったら
あなたその人見たことがありますか？と聞いちゃってバカバカしいでしょうね
でも 人間の場合はそうなんですけど
例えば 私にジーザスがこういうことを言いました
何々さんがもう親鸞聖人が私にこういう霊言融合
何でしたっけ？言いましたとかね
現代誰々が本を書くと
ことがあるのかと聞きたくなるでしょうね
でも日本人は聞かない
そうですかねとか すぐ信じる
だからブッダの言う霊言
親鸞の霊言 日蓮の霊言
昭和天皇の霊言もあります
あったっけ 昭和天皇がこう言ったとかね
中村先生とかね 言いたい放題
で 世界に世界で人間が尊敬しているあの人
人格あれば死んじゃうと誰かさんのところに行って申し訳ありませんでした
あなたのことはバカにしちゃったとか言うんだそうです
あなたの教えは正しかったんですねとかね
こういう話はね で 言うんだから信じるぞという性格っていうのはあまり良くない
仏教から見れば良くないんです
別な立場から見ればいいかもしれませんだけど
何でも信じる人々からすっごく素直でありがたいと
で 仏教にはすごい迷惑なんですよ
そういうもう素直で何でもよく聞いてくれる人間っていうのはね
だからマハーリーはそんなもう霊言霊言みたいなものをお釈迦様が言ってもね
会ったことはあるのかと
だからアリストテレス
アリストテレスであろうか
ソクラテスであろうが
ブッダであろうか ジェズスであろうか
もうもう何でしたっけ
このアブラハムであろうか
もうえーと あの王様はなんでしたっけ？頭いいっていうと
ヨーロッパに うーんと
とにかくもうみんな会って喋ってるんですね
あの人と 日本のあの偉い人と
それがすごい素晴らしいという風に思っちゃうとね
で でも一つありますよ
自分で把握できないところには立ち触らないんです
ただ 一般的に私が悪かったぐらい
で なんでアインシュタインに会って相対性理論についてもうちょっとわからないところいろいろあるんですけどね
そこを聞いてくれないんですかね
そういう人々とは喋れません
そういう人々に喋っても
アインシュタインでも後でちょっと神秘的宗教的になって死んじゃったんだから
そこら辺で そこらそのところで
やっぱりあなたに会うことできなかった
申し訳ありませんでしたとかね
そういうとこだけ遺言を霊言がする
だからこのマハリーさんがお釈迦様は本当に帝釈天に会ったことはあるのかと疑問したことはすごい健康的なんです
私は前おかしいと言ったんですけど
そうおかしくはないんです
それを聞くべきなんです
ただ鵜呑みにするんじゃなくて
それでこの帝釈 まあこの人間はね
嘘を言ってもいいんだけど
嘘を言う人もやっぱりもうちょっとまともな嘘を言ってほしいんですよ
ねえ だからもうあれほどダサい嘘を言って
それでも信じる人々のことを私はどう考えればいいのかと
嘘を言う場合はいくらかちょっと調べて
ちょっとバレないようにというところも必要なんで
そこまででも研究しないところは面白いんですね
で 帝釈天のこういう神々連中には寿命とかあるんだから
ヒンドゥー教からパクっちゃっても
ヒンドゥー教では永遠だからね
神々は 俺も帝釈天に生まれ変わっていた俺はと言えないはずでしょうに
だからおそらく仏教から盗むでしょ
仏教ではやっぱり生まれたやつは死ぬんだから
たとえ神になってもやがて死ぬ
でも仏教は曖昧で やがて死ぬとは言わないし
各次元には寿命を設定しているんです
犬だったら年とかね 人間だったら年だとか
寿命は設定しているんですよ
だったら帝釈天だったら何？寿命は何年かと
で設定しているんだから
一応人の話盗むんだったらね
そこら辺も寿命ぐらい見て
そこら辺で計算して やった方がいいのに
例えば小澤一郎がダイバだったの生まれ変わりやと言うでしょ
私個人的な あくまでも個人的な感想で
政治家の中でも結構正直な人なんですけど
結構もうバリバリプロで頑張り屋で
もういい加減で 自分の懐を増やすために政治やってるって気持ちではなくて
知ってるんだから何かやってあげたいという
これのためにやってる
すごくいい人なんですけど
これがデイヴァダッタの生まれ変わりだからね
かわいそうで だからそうやって人を侮辱して
自分の宗教を信じる人々に投票させてもらいたくて
そんなことを言っても
だから人の話盗んだからちょっと計算してほしい
デイヴァダッタっていうのは明らかにブッダの話でしょうね
ブッダに関わる話でしょうし
ブッダに逆らって地獄に落ちた人でしょうし
で 仏教はただ感想を述べるんじゃなくて
それなりに客観性がって言うんだから
デイヴァダッタ落ちた地獄はアジ
アジ アヴィーチ地獄と言うんだよと
なんであれにアヴィーチ
あれがもうたくさんいるんだから
あちらにはね それで苦しみにはもう休みないんだと
他の地獄だったら まあまあ一応プログラムがあって
一つのプログラム終わると次の
だから一つの苦しみプログラムから次の苦しみプログラムに移転するところでもちょっと一休みできるでしょうね
これないんです 一つのプログラムで寿命終わるまで苦しまなくちゃいけないんです
で まあそれだけのことで
で このアヴィーチ地獄の設定から見ると
このあるところに生命が生まれ変われる
生まれ変わったら そのあるその場所のそのものと一体になる
そうすると その場所が壊れない限りは
その生まれた人も壊れないんです
このアチ アヴィーチ地獄
日本ではアジビ地獄なんとか言うでしょうと思いますけど
そちらっていうのは別に他の地獄より怖いっていうわけでもない
大したことはないんですけど
で 一旦生まれたら その
例えば部屋と部屋にしましょう
その部屋の一部になる
柱とかなんとかとか 部屋の柱とか壁とかになっちゃうと
植木鉢に 植木になったらね
もう嫌だったら捨てちゃえばいいでしょ
でも部屋がある 部屋に何か机とかなんとか買ってきたならば
これ嫌になっちゃったならば処分すればいいでしょうに
でも部屋がある でも部屋構成
構造の柱とかね 壁とかどうするんですか
嫌になったんだからといって
これやっぱり部屋を壊すことになるんですね
だからこのアジビ地獄の場合は
生まれる生まれる生命でその地獄が構成されているんです
だから 寿命を計算する場合は
このアジブ地獄の寿命
例えば地球の寿命がありますね
それ同じ感じでアジブ地獄の寿命がそちらに苦しんでいる生命の寿命なんです
ということは あちらだけは一旦入っちゃうとえらい大変なことになるんです
他の地獄はすごい苦しいかもしれませんだけど
生命としているんだから早く死ぬんです
アジブ地獄にしちゃうとそれできない
地獄そのものが潰れるまでいなくちゃいけないんです
だから生命も数が多すぎ
地獄の人々ももうこちらで人間やらいろいろ悪いことしてアジブ地獄に落ちる
落ちたならばもう落ちたら落ちたでそちらにいよう
いなさいということになるんです
新しい生命が生まれるは
古い生命が死んでいくわというサイクルじゃないんです
だから そういう生命の次元もあるんだぞと仏教で説明あるんですけど
これ中途半端で読むんだから
そんな地獄あるのかないかはどうでもいいんです
私にとってもね 一応そういう風に物語でにしたっても
書く場合は仏教ならそれなりにいくらか論理的には書く
なんでアジブ地獄嫌がるのかというと
そのわけなんです 苦しみは最悪というわけでもないんです
あちらだけはしまったと言っちゃったところで
もう地獄そのものを壊れるまでいなくちゃいけないんだと
例えば地球に生まれて地球が破壊するまでいなくちゃいけないということになるような感じなんです
だから早く死ぬことはできないという状態で
これでアジブ地獄といったっても
すべて地球関係のものだから
一応寿命は地球の寿命なんです
だから一旦降りた人々は
この地球 今の太陽系の生命体系が壊れるまでいなくちゃいけないんです
それがアジブ地獄の寿命です
ということは ダイブダッタがいまだにいるはずなんです
たったこの二千 せいぜい二千五百年
六百年もなってないぐらいのところで亡くなった人でしょ
生まれたばっかしなんです
そこで確実にこの この人がね
誰でしたっけ 小沢さんがダイブダッタの生まれ変わると言った人をね
この人 あんた知ってますかね
我々のブッダ様がね ここまで知ってるんだよと
私はなるほど でもちょっと
ちょっとおかしい疑問があるんだよと
私もあなた知ってますかね
アジブ地獄の寿命はとかね
これぐらいですけど あなた方のブッダ様が知ってますかと
そんなあなたよりはブッダが知ってますよと向こうは言うんですね
言ったら だったらダイブダッタが今まだいるでしょうにと
ちょっとブッダ様がちょっと調べると
何か間違ったことないんですかと
いえ ブッダに間違いはない
あなたが間違っているんだと
怒涛でブッダいうことを信じないんだから
だからこれ話作った人のものは捨てて
今の人の話を信じなさいと
まあどうでもいいんですけどね
でもっと攻めちゃうと
とことん論理的に攻めてみたんで
それで 攻めてみたら あ
そうかもしれませんだけど
早く生まれ変わってるんです
その人だけ なんで？だって何々さんがそう言ってるんだからと
はい よくわかりましたと
もう二度と来ないでくださいと
私の部屋にはと 言っておいたんだけど
しょっちゅう来たんです
どんな嫌がらせしたっても来るんですよ
それで私にもネタ切れで
これ以上どんな嫌がらせすればいいかわからなくなっちゃったんです
何をしてもまたもう訪ねてくるんだから
本当にもう人間では理性があった方がかっこいいんですよ
だから私はいかにそういう人々を今侮辱しているかというとね
もう二足に四がわかるぐらいでも能力ない人々と私は今喋ってるでしょうに
本当は立派な仕事をしている
銀行のエリートの仕事をしているという人々なんですよ
だから銀行は倒産するのは当たり前ですよ
日本でどんな会社でも
あれほど精神伯爵社がやってるんだから
当たり前に私はびっくりでもなんでもしない
何々金融関係 ああ 潰れた
ああそう ということでね
本当に素晴らしい で それでこのお釈迦様に聞くんです
あんた見たことがあるのかと
それでこのお釈迦様に聞いたら見たことあります
お釈迦様 何言うんですか
もうそっちを見てるんだ
見たことはありますよと
したら マハーリーさんがサッカ退色点というのはそう見えるものじゃないんだよと
人間には だから神々を見たいという修行はインドでやってますよ
仏教の世界では この阿弥陀じゃない
誰だったか 阿弥陀さんやら観音さんやら見たいという修行をやっている方々いるんです
で 観音道場というものがあって
そこでいろいろ行をやる
行をやると阿弥陀様 観音様が見えると
だいたい夢で見えるという話ですけど
見えたら全ての希望が叶いますよと
日本にも一つお寺がありますけど
ただそちらに寝たままでいるだけで
なかなか見えないんですけど
韓国だったら立派な道場がありまして
そちらではすごい厳しい行をやるんです
で やっても何でもする
見えるんだったらもう麻薬でも何でもやる
で 夢に見えると それでこの浄土系の阿弥陀様を信仰する宗派がいくつかあります
そちらでも修行して修行して修行して阿弥陀様を見たいというね
修行もあります ですから
神を見たいという修行っていうのはキリスト教にもあります
これ何年も隔離して 自分をね
俗世間と全く関係を持たないで
ものすごい厳しく行をするんですよ
阿弥陀様を見たいという行の場合は
何日かわからないんです
何週間かわからないんだけど
一瞬も寝ないで修行するんです
歩きながら念仏を唱えて唱えて
大変ですよ そこでもいくら食べないでは大丈夫ですけど
人間が眠くなって倒れるでしょ
そうするとお世話係の人々は大きな棒を持って
棒にこうやって腰を支えるような何か作って
そこで腰を支えてあげるんです
それで行者が歩いて歩けて修行するんです
で あれをしても見えないのはどういうことか
別にわかりませんだけど
私はだいたい私だったら一晩徹夜しちゃうと見えますよ
例えばどんな仏像の前でも
何か仕事をして 仕事で疲れて疲れて統一するでしょうね
その時はもう夢 パッと夢でもずっと見てたものだから見えますけどね
なんでああいう方々に見えないんでしょうかね
なんか恨みでもあるんでしょうかね
阿弥陀様が わからないんですけど
カトリック カトリック教の方々はね
やっぱりイエスかマリアか
誰かが見たくてね 修行するんですけど
恨まれてるんでなかなか見えませんね
で 私は例えば遊びに教会なんかに行って喧嘩でもしちゃうと
やっぱり あの やっぱり気持ちが落ち着かないんですよ
いろいろ喧嘩ばっかりしちゃうとね
で 向こうは言葉上手だったら
ちょっと悔しいってことあるでしょ
明らかに悔しいって気持ちあったら
その夜は夢で見るんですよ
そんな簡単に見える 夢で見えるものはね
何でそういう立派な方々に見えないのかっていうことは分かりませんが
とにかくそうやって見える話があって
そのために必死で修行する
それでなんで見えないとわかりますかね
もともと信じてないんですよ
だから千日行やるんですよ
見たくて 見えるわけないでしょうね
どうせアホなことだからね
ちょっと頭がグダグダしてたら見えるもんやって知ってる私にとってはもう何でも見える
夢ですけどね 誰にでも見えますよ
だって子供でも夢で怪物を見たりするでしょうに
ゲームばっかりやったりしてね
あの恐怖映画でも見てください
見てそのまま寝てみてください
夢ではまた出ますよ あの連中が
だからまあそんなに単純なのにね
だから例えば私にしても
このエイリアンみたいなね
映画 変とかれんな映画を見る時でも
やっぱり見ている間は信じてあげますよ
でなきゃ見られませんしね
映画を あ これはやばいと
こうなっちゃうと困ったんだ
別にそんなこと何もないんですけどね
ただの映画でしょうに
こうなるとこれがやべえとね
あの人やられそうとかね
そうやって見ているんだから
そのまま寝ちゃうとまた夢でも出てくるんです
やっぱりそれぐらいも信じてないんですね
だからすごく修行するんですよ
見たくて見たくて でも見て見せてくれない
何て言いますかね 恨まれてるかどうか分からないんですけど
また信じてるんだったら見なくたっていいでしょうにね
絶対神様は信じているんだと
だから見たくて修行だったらやめろと
もうまあ そういう世界で
だからインドにしても当たり前だから
あの神この神見たいというね
修行はあるんです だから世の中でそうやってあの神この神見たいと修行する人々にしても
そこら辺にいる格の低い神々を狙ってるんですよ
誰も帝釈天は狙わないんです
神様は神々の王様だから
会ったことはありますよと
平気で言うと お釈迦様
お釈迦様 あれ結構難しいんだよと言うんです
見るのは そしたらお釈迦様はね
私はあいつは知ってますよと
釈迦は帝釈はね 天は それだけじゃなくて
どうすればそういう風に天国に生まれ変われるのかと
そこまで知ってます あの人は何をして帝釈天になったかという
その人の話まで知ってますよと
全部知ってますよ あの人のことならという
言ってそこでもう仏教が紹介したがる
インドラ神の神の王様の帝釈天の物語は
そちらでもう真の物語をもう紹介しちゃうんです
とにかく仏教は何やろうがしてるけど
この戦争の神を別な神に塗り直すんです
結構するがすごいこと仏教はやってます
塗り直すんですよ もう
本当はものすごい恐ろしい顔をして
もう戦いの神で キリスト教の戦いの神って何でしたっけ？ 聖人ですか
そうそうそう セントアンソニーかな
セントマイケルがいて
セントアンソニーがいて
みんな戦うんだからね
でもあのおれ一人が特別に戦いの神としてセンテントニアと思いますけどね
まあでもキリスト教の方々のちょっと思考はちょっとわからない
戦いの神の聖人の人相はありますよ
あっちこっち作っちゃって
だったらもう鉄砲ぐらい機関銃ぐらい持って作った方がいいし
あるいは昔のものだから弓でも持って作った方がいいのに逆なんです
矢であっちこっち撃たれてバカみたくもう負けて待ってる
これ違うんじゃないか
お前負けてるんだから誰がお祈りするんだと
試験合格してくださいとかね
大体試験合格でも一つの戦いだからね
あの聖人にお祈りするんですよ
あいつはとっくに負けてるんだから
別になんだ思考はちょっとね
あべこべなんです だから負けても悔しくないぞという禁じだったら分かりますけど
負けるために試験は落第するために
落第したらあとその処理のためにお祈りするのはね
でもイエスが磔されてる像がぐらいだから
槍打たれて  イエスの場合はちゃんとした物語だから
それはそれでいいんですよ
釘打たれたというのはね
それから左の方に何とか槍でやられたっていうのは
ちゃんとした物語でしょ
その物語を表現するための人相の人相はそれでいいんです
理屈通ってるんです このマイカル君やらあんたに君やら
そういう聖人たちは何なのかとわからないんです
この間 今度聞いてみます
専門家に 私の解説 まあとにかく
それでお釈迦様はこの物語を言うんですよ
この人は昔人間でしたと
名前はマグワというかね
マグワ マグワンという名前の人間でありましたと
それでこの仏教が面白いんですよ
だから何かなにかの物語を言うような感じでね
まあこの浦島太郎の物語みたいな感じで
もうそのような感じで
まあ昔はマグワという名前の人間いましたと
そこでインドラ神に名前はいくつかあります
この人は先へ先へと この当時で誰よりも先に人々を助けるんだ
お布施するんだと 何か困っている人があったら
みんなで助けましょうというけど
この人は先にやっちゃうと
どこも例えばイランで地震が起きて
もう今大変な苦しい状態でいるって
世界各国各国からもう援助が行くでしょうに
この例で考えちゃうと
この人はもう誰よりも先にもう自分援助を持って行ってるんだという感じで
だからいつでも人にお布施する状況が現れてると
このマグワンがもう先へ先へと
他の人々はお布施持っていくと
もうこの人先に持ってやってるんですね
そうやって何でもいいことは先にやろうと
それはパーリ語でプリモプリモと呼んで
それは あるいはプレープレー
これはファースト 先っていう意味で
そこでプレー 先にやるんだだから彼にプリンダダと言うんだよと
プリンダダっていうのは帝釈天のもう一つの名前なんです
その名前を分析すると
プリンダダっていうのはどんな
あげた人というか ダーナのね
あげた人ということだから
ププレっていうことはプリにして
で プリンダダ まあそれでも覚えやすいプリンダダですからね
まあプリンぐらい覚えるでしょう
ダダ入れちゃえば帝釈天の名前で
で こうやってこの これはお釈迦様が付けた名前じゃないんですけど
一応一般民俗 民が帝釈天が神様がプリンダダと言いますよと言うと
お釈迦様は あれはあの人は誰よりも先にお布施したんだからですよと説明するだけの話です
そこでそれを塗り直すんですよ
仏教は 人の話をね 人の大事な宗教的な神話を
仏教道徳で塗り直しちゃう
良いことっていうのは先にやれとという話にするんです
みんなやってるんだから
嫌々でやったってもかっこ悪いんだよと
だからいつでもリーダーシップを取って
自分を先にいいことをして
もうみんなでやりましょうという感じでやらなくちゃいけないんです
例えば国際的な援助でも
あの国に言われて この国に言われて
アメリカから言われて
国連から言われて ああそうですか
ではもう私たちもこれぐらいって援助するそうと言っても
いくら多額を援助したっても
やっぱり評価がかなり低くなっちゃうんですね
国際的に誰も援助する
そんな事件が起きたっていうことも知らないうちにさっさと察知して
もうもうそれなりにちょっとの額でもいいんだけど
額を援助して みんなに行って
こういうことは大変になってますから
みんなで頑張りなさいと言っちゃうと
やっぱりあの人々の先をもう一本取られたということになるんですよ
だからやっぱり先にやった方がいいことはね
かっこいいんです それを言ってるんです
こちらで その他大勢やってるんだから
まあしょうがないよ やっぱり俺もやるのかっていう感じ
大体みんなそういうことでしょう
みんなどれぐらいいいことしたら
見てみて じゃあみんなそれ
じゃあじゃあまあしょうがない
自分もという そういう徳の積み方っていうのはすごくダサいんですよ
なぜダサいと言うんですか
だから結果もそういう結果になるんですよ
いつでもなんか光がなくて
力がなくて なんか控えめでいなくちゃいけないんですね
いい 私はいいよということで
表には出ないんです だからそれはもう大勢の人々っていうのはあまり表に出たがらないし
それもう美徳したってもあまり意味がないんですよ
もう後ろばっかり群がってる人っていうのは
この気持ち悪いんですよ
はっきり言えば なぜかというと
僕らはもう職業柄いつでも前に立たなくちゃいけないし
いろんなものを管理しなくちゃいけないし
いろんな人にあれこれやと命令しなくちゃいけないし
これは嫌でもやらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そうするとみんな自分で後ろへ後ろへ探して
別の人に いいいい 私は結構そんな大事なことできないできないと言っちゃうとね
どういう気持ちと思いますかね
ああ まあいいや やりますと言っちゃうと
リーダーする人々にとってはものすごく救われますよ
では 君がこれやって 君がこれやって
君がこれやって このじゃあこういう風にしましょうと
わかったのとか はい わかりましたと
任せとけと言ってくるだったらありがたいんですけど
これがあっち見てこっち見て尻込みしちゃうと
全く管理できなくなっちゃうんですよ
だからもう何者かと そういうことで
結構人が好く場合はもう誰でもやると思います
結構人々カットするんですよ
まああんた方はいいやと
あんたもいいやと これかわいそうですよ
その人にも能力あるんですよ
何かできることあるんですよ
できることやっちゃうとすごく気持ちもいいし
でもいつでも後ろ後ろなっちゃいますから
私はものすごい侮辱的な名前までつけてるの
自分のお寺の信者さんに
であれはもう日本訳できないほどすごい侮辱なんです
まああの村人はもう本気になって訴えられるほどできますよ
自分たちをものすごく侮辱しているんだと言って
裁判で訴えることもできるぐらいの侮辱の言葉を使っているんです
何をしたってもいつでも後ろに行くんです
表には出てこない これでも村のことって何一つもできないでしょうに
裏ではいくらでもいるんですけど
表では一人もいない状態だから
こういうことだから ものすごく侮辱するような
もうあんた方はこういう民族だからとか何とかって言ったら始まります
それでもそうすると人の間で一人二人ぐらい
まあどうしようもないってことで前に来るんです
そこでは強引にきつく逃げられない
逃げられないようにも罠を仕掛けておいて
仕事をさせるんですよ
いろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんだ
例えばお正月の何かやりましょうと言ったっても
誰かが管理しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから若い人も人々もたまに何か何かそうやってこの催し物とかもやりますけど
いつでもいろいろ一回しかやらないんです
なぜかというと その人にとってはもうあの 一回何かやって
その苦しみはもう二度と味わいたくないってことなんです
あの人々とやらなくちゃいけないんだから
みんなもう後ろ裏口でいるんです
というか スリランカでは裏裏にあるのは便所なんです
この家の中に便所作れませんだからね
みんなそちらに裏返ってるんです
玄関ではないんです だから便所を掃除するのはね
カーストの一番低いカーストだからね
だから私はどういうふうに侮辱するかといくらか推測できると思います
やっぱりそれが私たちに侮辱する権利はないんですよ
人々はね やっぱりただ冗談で言ってるだけの話で
本気になって侮辱してはいけないし
人間が自分がやった行為によって今の結果でしょうし
だから前に出なさいよと言っても
本人には出られないんですよ
別に何か悪いことしてるわけじゃないんですよ
何か恥ずかしいことをしてるわけでもないんです
でも出られない 例えば
あなたはこの研究を発表しなさいと言っても
自分がダメですよと言ってる
別にその人は研究しないでごまかしやってるわけじゃないんですよ
ちゃんと研究などはやってます
だからせっかくあんたやったんだから
あなた発表しなさい それだけはごめんと
だからやっぱりそれは業の結果なんですよ
表に出てリーダーシップを取れないというね
そこで仏教が言うのは
何かやるんだったら先にやりなさいと
みんなやってるんだから
では俺もちょっと参加しますというね
態度ではあまりにもこのオーラというか
人間としてのね パーソナリティというかね
あれがないんですよ 存在感というかね
何て言いますか 日本語で
存在感ですか  存在感とか威力というかね
何かね  風格ですか  風格
威力 もうなんとかすごい力がね
あるでしょうに これがなくなっちゃうんですね
すごいオーラがあれば
どこででも大丈夫でしょうしね
だからただ単にもうそこら辺の人間に生まれたんではなくて
かなりオーラがあって
風格があって 威力がある
もう結構もう存在感がある人間で生まれた
生まれ変わりたければ
やっぱり良いことをする時は先にやるというね
決してこの何でも後ろに下がる下がる工程で考えてはいけないんです
こんなこと本当にできるのかな
こんなという 絶対言ってはいけないことなんですよ
これ難しくないよ やればみんなでやりましょう
やりましょうという性格だったらね
だからいろんな計画っていうのは立てるということで
もうわかる論理でしょうに
もう簡単にできるものだったら計画立てる必要もないでしょうに
ご飯食べましょうという計画は食べます
立てないでしょうに でも人に接待しましょうと言っちゃうと計画立てる
だから何か計画を立てて何かやるということでも
大胆なことをやるやる意味なんですよ
今の自分ではできないのはもう決まりきっていることでしょうに
分かりきっていることでしょうに
そこで尻込みしちゃうと全て終わっちゃうんです
だから計画は大胆でやりましょうと
これどうやればできるでしょうかというふうにポジティブで考えるのであってね
逆に考えちゃうんですね
それを逆に考えると もう徳がほとんど消えてしまっているんです
だからもう結果いる時でも
全然風格も威力も何もなく
存在感もない人間で生まれちゃうんですね
だから いわゆる英語でマジェスティという言葉がありますよ
マジェスティっていうのは王様っていうぐらいのその性格です
それがなくなっちゃうんですね magnificent
という言葉や だいたい日本語でも使ってますかね
これ平仮名 カタカナ発音で言えばわかるでしょう
Magnificent 英語で言えばね
吸引力 磁力  すごいって意味なんだ
サンチュン それマジェスティって
いわば人を呼ぶ時は閣下と言うんですけど
マジェスティっていう名詞ありますよ
日本語だと神様ですかね
何々の神様  まあそれで帝釈天にはプリンダダという名前ありますよとお釈迦様が説明する
これなんでプリンダダと呼ぶんでしょうかというと
その人は良いことをする場合は先にやる
自分が最初にやる だから今天国に生まれて
これでまた王になってるんだと
だからなんだよという意味で言ってるんです
だから仏教にしてみれば
別に帝釈天がどうでもいいんですよ
仏教が人間に生き方を教えてるだけなんです
あんた方の性格直せと
そんなもう便所 便所周りばっかりじっと座り込んでいたってもね
これ立派な人間になるわけじゃないんだよと
ちゃんとリビングで堂々と座っている人間が欲しいやと
だから まあそういう この私も日本でも何回も使ってますけど
便所掃除っていうね この前も日本の自衛隊が何かにどこかに行っちゃったんでしょ？便所掃除に
今度も同じことでね ああいう風に
この後から後片付けに行くっていうのはね
だからそれなりに力があるんだから後片付けに行くんですけど
でもかっこ悪いんですよ
日本の軍隊にもものすごい力がありますし
能力もありますけど アメリカ軍隊の便所掃除に行くと
イラク戦争あった時もそうでしょう
行ってちょっとスパイと情報調べて
こういうレポート はいこういう
それぐらいの仕事に ただ自分たちも行った
参加しましたっていうことを言いたいだけで
やっぱり掃除に行くんですよ
私の単語で言えば 便所掃除に行くんですね
だからやっぱりメジェスティっていうものはないんですね
先に行くということは
決して戦争に先に行ってはいけないんですけど
そこはやっぱりどこででも見られるんですよ
悪いことでははっきり見られるんですけど
いいことでも見られるんですね
やっぱり結構遅く行って参加すると遅くと
ほとんど祭りはもう終わっているというかね
祭りの最後のところで行っても
だったら後片付けを頼むぞということになるんです
あんた方の残り物を食べて
後片付けも頼むぞと かっこ悪いんで
祭りが始まるとこ テープカットに行って
万々歳で行って もうそこでやって
じゃあ私は時間だから帰りますよと言ったらカッコいいのにね
だからこの これは人格的な性格的な問題で
私たちはこの世界で どんな世界ででも
やっぱり存在感があって生きていないとカッコ悪いしね
立場がなかったら会社に行ったって
まああんたも来たのという状態だったら気分悪いんですよ
すごくストレス溜まっちゃうし
例えば仕事を頼む時でも
何か資料も机の上に投げちゃって
じゃあこれやりなさいという状態で命令されるってかっこ悪いでしょうに
まだ終わってないの？いつまでやるつもりですかとか
会社で言われると もう自殺したくなるでしょうに
人格がなくなっちゃって
でもちゃんと威力ある人だったらそうじゃないんですよ
頼む人はファイルで これお願いしますという感じでしょうに
だから会社に行っても
学校にどこ行っても その人にはそれなりの風格
威力 存在感というのはないと
もう最悪ですよ 別にみんな社長にならなくてもいいんですよ
それは問題ない 会社で掃除するおばさんもいるでしょうね
おばさんっていうのは失礼ですけど
掃除する係もいるでしょうに
床掃除やら事務所掃除やらね
机拭いたりとかね 別にどうってことないんですよ
でも その人にはちゃんとした風格
威力はあってほしいんです
そういう場合はちゃんと掃除に来ると
みんなきちんともう今掃除の時間だから
はいどうぞって感じになるでしょうに
あんたうるさい 今忙しいんだから別な時来いと言っちゃうと
掃除する人がなんかえらい惨めで身分が小さくて
今掃除してもよろしいでしょうか？という状態になるんです
掃除 今掃除する時間ですよと
あるいは仕事中 机なんか汚れたっても
掃除する人にはすごい威力あるんだったら
今日は怒られそうとかね
言うんですよ 一言葉でも
あるいはその人までだけ
ごめんね ちょっと汚れましたけどとかね
一言葉言うんですよ 今日ごめん
ちょっと汚れましたけど
お願いしますと そうやって掃除する人に社長が頼むんだったら
掃除する人さえも立派な人間として生きているんです
これがほとんど社会では見られません
なぜかというと 我々は徳を積む時でも
ああいう態度で徳を積んでいるんだから
かも だからそういう帝釈天なんぞやと言いたくはないんです
仏教は それで 人間にはこういう風に生きてみなさいよということ
誰でもいいんだから 王でいなさいと
掃除する掃除担当の王様とかね
資料担当の王様とか みんな王様でなければいけませんと
受付の王様とかね 誰でも王様の格好でいればいいでしょうに
それが生命の尊厳ということなんです
それで この帝釈天にはパーリ語でサッカという名前があるんです
SAKKA これ なんであの人のサッカ
おそらくインドで誰でも誰でも言っていたんですよ
シャッカ サンスクリットのシャッカなんですね
だからシャッカという言葉はこの神の王様に使っていたんですよ
みんな それでお釈迦様はこれ塗り直す
どうやって塗り直すと
サッカっていうのはパーリ語でサンスクリット語でよく上手によく丁寧にという意味なんです
その意味でも使う あ 上手ですという場合も使う
だから我々は何かやる場合はすごく上手で丁寧にやっちゃうと結構かっこいいんです
それでその言葉 サッカという言葉はなんでインドラ神に使うかというと
お釈迦様 あの人はお布施なんかする時はとても上手に
とても丁寧に とても丹念にやっていたんだと
いわゆる投げじゃないんです
いわゆる投げ捨てというかね
捨て なんでわかりません
まあじゃあ持っていけ
もううるさいという感じでね
そういうことではなくて
すごく丁寧に心こもってお布施など善行為をしていたんだと
だから 小さな小さな良いことでもする時は
すごく丁寧で心こもってやっていたんだから
それにパーリ語でサッカという意味なんです
サッコーダーナンデーティという
だからサッコーと言うんだよと
だって語呂でわかるでしょ
あるいはサッカートアダーナンデーティ
タスマサッコーティウッチャティ
サッカートアダーナンデーティ
だからサッコーやと 語呂で作ってるんですよ
だからこの語呂をとって
仏教は別なことを喋ってるんです
あの神様はもう完璧にもう塗り直し
だから何かやるんだったら丁寧に上手にやれと
いい加減でふざけてどうでもいいという感じで
中途半端で雑で何もするなよと
いや それが気持ち悪いんだと
だからみんな自分のことを褒めてくれない
褒めてくれない 認めて
認めてくれないと泣いてるでしょうに
そういう泣く必要ないんですよ
例えば私の仕事ももうボロボロ老人になったんですけど
誰もはっきり理解してみないでしょうに
どれほどのことを苦労してやっているのかと
ないような もしかすると0001も理解していないと思いますけど
私は文句は言ってないんですよ
侮辱はしているんですけど
ああ しまった 先生わかってくれないとかね
逆にわかるわけないでしょうと
で なんでそういう態度をするかというと
やっぱり自分は自分なりに
客観的にどうか分かりませんだけど
自分の主観から見ると自分が精一杯やっている
それはすごく丹念に丁寧に
見事に これでも文句あるのかというぐらい
自分は自分の主観から見れば
自分のもう私見から見ればそこまでやってるんだから
もう悔しくはないんです
もう客観的にあなたの話はダサいやと
もう発音が悪いんだから
何言ってるか分からない
また長すぎやと これで人間の頭はそんなに集中力ないんだよとか言われることもありましたけど
もうまあそれはまあその通りでしょうけど
だから客観的に見たらごちゃごちゃはあるんですよ
どんな人間にも でも やってる本人がきちんと精一杯悔しくない状態でやればこれで十分ですよ
だから社会人としてみんなそれがないんだから
なんかどこかで手抜きをする
どこかで中途半端でやっちゃう
で だから手抜きで中途半端でやるんだから
ちゃんと認めてもらう
判子押してもらうまでビクビクしているんですね
これでいいか あ よかったよかったとか
なんだあれはと 別に自分は自信
自分には自信満々だったらね
それで十分でしょうに
向こうは向こうから見て見て却下されても
だからそれも人間に幸福に生きるために必要な大事なポイントなんです
だから 社長が仕事は却下するかもしれませんよ
いくら必死で社員が仕事をしたんだからといって
なんだかんだOKするわけにはいきませんでしょうに
でも自分のプログラム却下されたんだからって
どうったことない 自分がすごく丁寧にきちんとそのプログラムを組んで提出をする
提出でもなんのことなく仕事終わったぞという感じで帰ればいいんです
これで膝が震えて待ってるんですね
OK が来るかないかとかね
大体私もレポート書く場はまあ何回あったんでしょう
やり直すっていうことは
あまりなかったんですけど
じゃあこれはちょっとまあやり直すことになった時でも
私は依然自信満々で まあその都度の教育関係だからね
上にいるのは自分たちの先生たちでしょうし
で 先生たちはやっぱりここまで仕事しているんだからね
なんか申し訳ない感じするんですね
これ 言いたくないという感じで
すぐ読めますからね 何かあるみたい
なんかあるみたい 何のことなく
先生何です 何ですかねとかね
堂々と聞く どこですかねと
ああ そうですね まあここら辺はまあこれこれこうなって
こうなって もうちょっと変わった方が
はい 分かりました もうやり直しですね
これはやり直さなきゃできない
先生負けは言わない 私は
これだったらこれ またもう一度やり直さないといけないんですよと
自分で言ってやり直すんです
先生も楽しいし 私も楽しいし
だから初めは手抜きしたならば
これ結構効くんです 戦争の中で
もし手抜きをしてそれを出して教授にバレると
もう痛む 大変なことで
どうせバレますよ 漏れは
これぐらいのことはもう
ですから 我々は仕事は完璧でなくてもいい
仕事は下手でもいい 自分の能力ですからね
もうやること やることはもうほとんど却下されちゃうと
たまにOKになるだけやと
それはそれでもいいんですよ
別に しかし 自分がやることは
自分の主観で 自分の気持ちで
自分の正直な心から見れば
俺が精一杯やってるんだよという
ぴったしやってるんだよという自己満足がなければ
もうどうしようもないんですよ
これは明らかに自己満足なんですけど
だから生きる上ではもう本当にもうしょうがない
もう人はどういうか分からないんですよね
だから明らかにやる分は自己満足でやる
それで社会に提供したところで
社会はどういうふうにそれに反応するかということは
これはこちら知ったものではありません
社会はこれはダメ やり直しですというのははい
分かりました やり直します
と言えばそれで終わり
どうせやり直しはとっても簡単なんです
一回やったものだから真面目に
余裕もある で やり直しちゃうとまたすごい能力がある
やり直しも丁寧にやりますから
だからここでこの なんで帝釈天に釈迦という言葉を使うのかというと
彼が徳を積む時はサッケーナというふうにやっていましたと
サッカットはダーなんだということで
だからそこでサッカットはという言葉とサッカという言葉で
語呂合わせで もうサッカと呼んでると
けど お釈迦様 仏教は逆に計算すると思いますけどね
本当はもともとサッカヤとサッカ様
サッカ様と言ってたでしょうね
インド人は サッカ様は今日はなんとかお願いしますとかね
お釈迦様はあんた知ってますか？なんでサッカ様と言うんですか？と
あれはあいつは人間でいて良いことをする時はものすごく丁寧にやったって見なよって言うと
言ってすごい具体的な
論理的な 合理的な道徳を紹介しますよ
この他人のエピソードをパクっちゃって
で 人の話取るんだったら
そういう風な取り方いいんですよ
相手に何も言えなくなっちゃいますから
これが私たちの話ではないかと
もうあなた方の話なんですよ
ここで訂正しましたよと
あまりもダサいんだからという態度でしょうに
だから前私は日本の例に言ったことは
仏教の話でもパクっちゃってもいいんだけど
もうちょっと訂正するなりにいい解釈だな
あちらの解釈もというね
びっくりするぐらいちょっと僅かでもあれば面白いのに
もう何やと それは全くない状態だからね
悲しいんですけど うん
それで 来たんですか？ あ
来ました  サッカ神様にもう一つ名前あります
ヴァーサワ ヒンドゥー教で全部ありますよ
こういう名前は ヴァーサワ
サッカ インドラ プリンダダ
これはどんなインドの人に聞いたっても大体わかると思います
でもサンスクリット語で聞かないとわからないかも
これで帝釈天にワーサワという名前があります
これなんでワーサワというんでしょうかというと
彼が人間にいた時は アーワサタというものは付随しましたと
アーワサタというのは家
住むところ 住むところ
いわゆる家 建物ですね
彼がない人々に家を作ってあげたんだと
結構頑張り屋さんで 家がない人々に
では家作ってあげましょうと
言って いろいろ木材をあちこちから持ってきて
それで家を建てて はい
どうぞこちらに住んでくださいと
いっぱいいるでしょうに
例えば何か体に障害あるとか
家建てられません 現代的に考えちゃうともう何の得も住めないんですよ
もうもう今はもう鬼だけの世界になっちゃってね
もう何だかんだも特許やらもうもう権利書あれこれとかね
汚いんですよ 昔そうじゃないんですよ
本当に美しい世界で 建物といっても自分であっちこっちから何か材料を持ってきて建てればいいし
そんな立派な豪華なものでなくてもね
もう楽に住めればいい
だからみんなそれぞれなりに作る
それでもちょっと体が弱い
足が弱い 手がもうなんとかっていう人だったら家が建てられないでしょうね
これ他にあんたには家が建てられないね
もうちょっと待ってね
わしが作ってあげますからと
言って そこで材料を持ってきて
それで家を作ってあげる
そちらにいろいろ粘土ありますから
粘土を持ってきて それちゃんと塗って壁を作ってあげたりとかね
結構気持ちいいんですよ
これしっかりしたビルになるとき
お布施できなくなっちゃうんですね
で とにかく現代世界っていうのはもう何でも商売
何でも商売 何でも儲かるというものことに
何か金儲かる方法ないんでしょう
もしかすると 人間が咳をしたらこれぐらいお金払えという風に何かシステム作るかもしれません
もう何でもいいんですよ
だからもう 汚いんですよ
まあそれが置いといて
この帝釈天にはワーサワという言葉を使います
なんでワーサワという言葉を使いますかというと
ワーサというのは住むところをあげたんだからと
そこでこのサッカ神様にサハッサッカと言うんです
サハッサネッティとも言うんです
サハッサッカサハッサネッティ
サハッサッカっていうのは目は千個あるんだと
目は目玉はね 千 すごい気持ち悪いでしょ
これが他の人々はね 本気でそれを信じるんです
だから考えてみてください
もう神の体中目が千個あると
体中目が目から座って座れないし歩けないし
で 仏教は乗り直すんです
そんなのは なんか聖書にも神様のそばに何か犬みたいな動物いるみたいですね
体中目があるんて思うと
それだったら結構不自由だなと思いますけどね
頭からお尻尾までをもう全部目
で こちらでなんでお釈迦様説明するの？なんで帝釈天にサハッサッカサハッサネッティと言うんでしょうか
全眼だと なんで言いますかと
あれが あの人はほんの僅かな
時間で千ぐらいの問題でも解決しますよと
ぐちゃぐちゃしないで
もうすぐすぐもうほんのちょっと時間があれば
あの人ならもう千ぐらいの問題でも解決するでしょうとみんな言うような人なんです
それぐらい活発なんです
人間でいた時は だから彼はこういう名前があるんだよと
そこでこのスジャンパティという名前もありますけど
スジャンパティというのはスジャという女の旦那という意味なんです
なんで女の人は使っているんでしょうかとね
あの女の旦那やという風に
これはスジャータという人が民族は違うんですね
だから全く違う民族の人と結婚しているんです
これまた仏教はかっこいいと思ってるものなんですよ
白人だったら黒人と結婚しろよという態度なんです
だから人間できてない場合は
我々白人だけ 我々黒人だけという風になっちゃうんです
あんた外人でしょうと
これやっぱり人間ってできてないんですよ
外人も三種類いると知ってますか
知らないでしょ 日本で外人は三種類います
外国人と外人と名前ない外人
三種類いるんです 外国人というのはヨーロッパ人
外人というのはだいたいインドか中東とか
そういう大きなもうアジア
中央アジア系の大国の人々
名前ないのはこの小さな国々から来ている人々という
やっぱり三種類いるんですよ
態度は三つなんです まあまあ
それも別にいいんですけど
例えばこの人間っていうのは自分だけ固まるということはありますし
それは弱いんだからね
あまりことじゃない だから他の人々とも堂々と交流を持った方がいいんですよ
みんな平等で だから何をという感じで交流を持った方が人間としては成長する
だから白人なら黒人と結婚した方がいいし
これは絶対認めない 法律的にも禁止というのはもうまだまだ原始人ですよ
もう文明はまだまだということで
で 例えば宗教違う場合はもう結婚を認めないとかね
結婚したら自分の宗教を信仰しなくちゃ
それはカトリック教でも決まりは結婚する人で
みんなカトリック教で洗礼を受けてカトリック教にならなくちゃ絶対禁止という
で でも誰もやって実行してないんですけど
イスラム教でも同じ 他の宗教と結婚してもいいんだけど
その人が必ずしもイスラムにならなくちゃいけない
女と結婚するんだったら
その女がイスラムにならなくちゃいけない
男と結婚するんだったら
その男はイスラムにならなくちゃいけない
厳しい だから それでは人間堕落する
だからもう誰は誰 誰が誰とともいいんじゃないんですかと
そこら辺まで仏教は考えて
この大釈典の特色っていうのは
このおきさきがまるっきり違う人間
神の世界では斯羅と阿修羅に分けてますから
だから阿修羅の人と結婚しているんだと
神々には斯羅というんです
おそらく人間にいた時は
この人はアーリア人で正真正銘の非アーリア系の人
女の人と結婚したでしょうと思います
アーリア系でないんだから結婚してやるぞと
ということだと思います
だからこの それも人間やっぱりやった方がいいっていうことなんですね
同じグループで固まってはいけない
危険ですよ すごい危険
例えばあの 皆様でもアメリカ人でもよろしい
イスラムの人々でもよろしいし
個人的に話してみてください
すごい立派な人々ですよ
もしパレスチナ人やらね
イラク人でもね 友達がいればもうイラク漬けになるぐらい人格はいいんですよ
みんな それ個人で付き合ってみると
でもそちらの仲間集めちゃうと何するかわからない
日本人も大したことはないんですよ
個人個人では結構立派ですよ
これがグループ組んじゃうとサリンでもまく
何でもやる でも個人で見たらものすごく真剣
真面目で まあ立派な方で
このなんだ この二重性っていうのはわかりますかね
学校に行く子供たちでも一匹取ってみたらすごく可愛いんですよ
言うことは聞くは ちゃんと挨拶もするは
ちゃんと靴を揃うは ものすごく可愛いんですよ
あれ三匹置いといてください
どこかに とんでもないことやっちゃうでしょう
ですから この人間にはそういう性格があります
自分たちだけ固まると
もう原子爆弾みたいに
分解しておくと何のことなくすっごくいいんです
だから人間っていうのは地球中入り交じった方がいいということは
仏教的な考え方なんです
入り交じった方がいいと
私は何人だと言えない状態を作れと
あなた何人？母親はあの人で
母親の両親はこの人で
この人で 父親がこれでこれで
一体私って何人か自分でわからないんだという状態だったら
本当に平和的な人間なんですよ
これは医学的には素晴らしい
全く違う性質の遺伝 交わりますからね
どんどん才能がもうある人間が生まれてくる
この遺伝の流れの場合は決まりがありますよ
だいたい弱いもの 弱い遺伝はもう隠れちゃうんですよ
後ろに下がるんですよ
いい力 強い遺伝子だけ機能しちゃうんでしょ
だから入り混じれば入り混じるほど
大体悪い性格合うということよりも
いい性格合体する可能性
確率は高いんです たまたま悪い性格も合体しますけど
やっぱりすごい確率低くない
だから混じった方がいい
帝釈天の話では 帝釈天にはスジャン
スジャンパティ スジャンパティって言うんだよと
過去悪業の女の名前で旦那を言うと
スジャンパティの夫やと言うんだよと
なんでスジャンパティさんはそんなに入らせてるんですかね
あれは真側 真側の民族の人ではありませんという意味なんです
こんな話はもういいや
いい加減にやりましょう
そういうことで この帝釈天の話
インドラ 神様 インドラ王様の話は
仏教はどんな形で どんな色で塗り替えたかとは見えますかね
全然神話でなくなっちゃうんですよ
まあ神話は神話で面白いんだから
もう勉強してもいいと
しかし我々には すごい具体的に現代的な生き方も同時にすっごいいいことを教えているんですよ
幸福でいるためにはこういうこういう特色を守れと
それで大釈尊が人間にいた時はこの七つの決まり守っていたんだと
それは私は両親を面倒死ぬまで見てやる
自分の親戚の中の目上の人々は死ぬまで尊敬してやる
自分が死ぬまで 私は死ぬまで優しい言葉をかかる
語る 他人に対して 相互は悪口は絶対言わないと
死ぬまで噂は言わない
他人の悪いことは言わない
死ぬまでケチな生活はしませんと
みんなと物事を分けて生活するんだと
いつでもこの開いた手で
あげる手で 自分が何か儲かっちゃうと誰かにあげようかなという気持ちで生活
そういう人々いますよ
何かもう庭で果物でも野菜でもできちゃうと
これが一番 あの人にはこれを
これあの人にとか もうすぐもうもう分ける計画できてるんですよ
これは自分で食うよりはみんなに分けて送ることが楽しくて楽しくてたまらないんです
これうちでできた庭でできた大根だよとかね
自分が作ったかぼちゃだよとかね
あっちこっちで送りまくったりしたりするでしょ
そういう人々の本当にもう送られた側が迷惑かもしれませんだけど
ものすごい立派ですよ
性格は すごく優しくて可愛いんですよ
だからそういう性格で
いつでももうみんなに配れるような気持ちでいるんだよと
それからそれから 頼み
同じポイントを頼みやすい人間
ものを頼みやすい人間でいるんだよということは
この死ぬまで怒りませんと
もし万が一怒ったら瞬時にこれ消すんです
怒りは そういう七つのルールがあったと
だからあの人は死んでからもう天国に行っただけじゃないんだよと
天国の王様になりましたと
そこで仏教のこの塗り直しの派手さ
普段は我々の民族のリーダーがこれぐらい戦って
これぐらい戦争して もう敵から私たちを守ってして
それで亡くなって天国に行って王様になったという戦争の話なんですよ
人殺しに話なんですよ
すべて文化は 西洋であろうが東洋であろうが
天国にいる王様たちはみんな人殺し屋なんですよ
たくさん人を殺したほど尊敬されませんよ
アレクサンダーやら何やらいるでしょうに
単純な人殺し屋でしょうに
だから歴史は人間はそうやって評価するんですよ
人殺し屋だったら神社まで作ってくれるんですよ
葬式に行ってみてください
葬式にも誰も来ないんですよ
やっぱりすごい悪人でいると
もうもう神社に葬られても拝んでくれるんです
これがもう人間の世界で
これ仏教を塗り直す これでこの
だからあえてマガの話だけを受け取る
マガワンという人が 私は死ぬまで怒りません
死ぬまで親を尊敬する
死ぬまで目上の人を尊敬する
死ぬまであれやこれやとかね
みんなに助けてあげる
もうもう頼みやすい人間で生活する
怒ってたまに怒っても瞬時に怒りを消す
消してやるぞという そういう性格でいたんだよと言って
我々にも間接的にこれこそ立派でかっこいいんだよと
人間だったらこういう生き方しなくちゃあかんのと
人殺すんじゃない 人殺して偉いと思わないよという話ですよ
誘導ミサイルでやったぞと言ったって
人殺しには変わりないでしょうに
より汚いんでしょ ああいう殺し方は
お互いにぶん殴り合っちゃって
一人が死んじゃっても
もうそれはかっこいいんですよ
戦って戦って戦って勝ったんだから
これでコンピューターから誘導ミサイルで10万人一発で殺したぞとかね
どうだい？我々の戦術
もうテクノロジーとかね
あんなものは何でもないんだよ
批判非難するべき そういう科学者はもう悪人扱いするべき
どんどん国民がね そういう軍事開発やら何やらね
あんなのは人間やるものじゃないんだと
もう悪魔の連中やってものすごく非難しちゃうと
いくらか社会が良くなると思いますけどね
でも世界はいつでもそういう人殺しを評価するという
賞賛するという傾向はずっとありますよ
今 最近のことじゃないんです
昔からもあったんですね
ですから 仏教は昔からもこれ何とかして塗り直そうと頑張っていたんですよ
だから仏教は結構やられます
社会から かわいそうに
悪いことしてないんだから
もう悪人ですね だからすごい難しい
仏教はあんまりみんなかっこ悪いと思うが
隠れてやろうとするわね
十字架だったらもうドーンと胸胸張って持って行くわ
まあまあ それはそれで
一応この対釈尊の物語でお釈迦様があるストーリーを言ってるんです
こちらでずっとあるのは人間でどうやって生きるべきか
それから仏教を見てる社会福祉
他人のために生きるっていう
そういう辺ですよ だから
人間として自分だけ食って生活することは放逸的な生き方で
俺が人々のために生きていけなくちゃいけない
やることをしっかりやらなくちゃいけない
自分で満足できるようなことをしなくちゃいけない
何かいいことをするんだったら
先にやらなくちゃいけない
みんなに尻を叩くまで待つんじゃないぞという
そういう生き方がアッパマーラなんです
偉い人格なんですよ なかなかこれ 1 日ではなくて
何十年に至ってもできるかなというぐらいの立派な生き方なんです
だから 今日のアッパマーラの定義はそれなんです
不放逸の定義は それも不放逸なんですね
何か会社で計画を頼まれちゃって
書きなさいと 自分では自慢できるようにしっかり書く
作る 悔いはないようにやろう
会社はそれを却下しようか OK
しようか それは無関係なの
それもアッパマーラなんです
真剣に親の面倒を見る
親を泣かすことは全くもしない
親に自慢できる人間で生きてみる
アッパマーラです それも
いつでも人を助ける アッパマーラなんです
これが今日の定義です
だからまた使うと思います
それで終了いたします
あの 本当は大釈尊の話はもう何ページ何ページ何ページもありますよ
この仏教で言っている社会福祉物語っていうのは懲りしがないんです
だから結構長いんです
仏教には社会福祉だけに殺す時間ないんです
たくさんの真理語らなくちゃいけないんだから
社会福祉はたった一項目で二
三ページで終了するんです
他の宗教のだったら すべて社会福祉だけで終わっちゃうでしょうに
我々はもっと仕事あるんです
だからそれはちょっとしかないんですよ
大釈尊の話だけで終わっちゃいますから
まだありますけど だからストーリーは長いんです
だから皆様自分自分で何か探して探して調べて読むしかないんですけど
読み方は私の読み方でなくちゃ意味がないんですよ
でもこれは日本語になっちゃうと
このサッカは好みでサッカになったとこは説明はないと思います
サッカっていうのは上手だから丁寧だからサッカと言うんだよというふうに
この語呂で語呂で言葉の語呂でストーリー作ってますから
パーリ語で読むと面白いんですけどね
ブリンダダという名前はもう先にオフセする人ということで
で まあ勉強をなさっても悪くはないと思います
では終了いたします どうもありがとうございます